every game from here on out is is big
right when you get to this time of year
and you get to the position that we're
in every game is big every game is
meaningful um
you know listen we understand the
playoff implications as a result of this
game you know
um but if you if you go in with that
mindset every week if you play with that
same mindset it's
it's like you're getting ready for the
super bowl every week you know it's like
you're getting ready for
that big game that meaningful game each
week so
if you prepare that way
if you if you believe that in your heart
then
when you step out there on sunday you
know that you've done everything you can
to put yourself in the best position to
win that's all you can do
hey drew shut up we're trying to play
ping pong over here i'd love to know who
was playing ping pong you could hear it
in the background as brees was talking
about the importance of this game and
this is a huge game this is in some
respects big cat i think a bigger game
in new orleans on sunday than ravens
49ers last week because this is for the
one seed you got the 10 and 2 49ers the
10 and two saints currently the saints
are the one seed because the 49ers
aren't even in first place in their own
division this is a hugely important game
and if the saints are going to pull this
one off they need brees to to play like
the guy he used to be he doesn't have
that arm to get the ball down the field
and they've been talking about using
taysom hill more i think they want to
get tased out there to uncork some deep
balls from time to time without creating
the impression they're floating drew
brees on an iceberg but this is a real
test because i think the 49ers are
better than the saints and we may we may
see that in very stark terms on sunday i
agree mike and i especially agree with
the taysom hill part if the saints want
to win this game i think they need to
use taysom hill more than they have in
the past because the 49ers defense is
that talented that if you can't stretch
the field on them they're going to just
keep coming up and coming up and coming
up and drewbry's going to have a long
sunday if they don't at least have the
threat that they can go deep and over
the top on the 49ers
sean payton said after last thursday
night's game when hill had a pair of
touchdowns and a block punt they
probably should use him more kyle
shanahan the coach of the 49ers said
earlier this week they are ready for it
they just don't know
what it's going to look like and that's
the genius of sean payton you never know
what he's going to draw up he will come
up with plays during the walk through
the night before the game and taysom
hill is good enough and his players for
the most part are flexible enough that
they can adapt and they can incorporate
they don't have to practice it 50 times
in order to make it happen and hill's
just a guy who has an incredible skill
set and you just got to get your best 11
guys on the field right it's that simple
he's one of your best 11 guys
offensively special teams and maybe even
defensively get him on the field more
yes absolutely and if you're drew brees
i know that he uh there might be a
little ego involved i'm not sure but you
know it's your team it's been your team
it's your franchise
actually it's you know you own the city
of new orleans so to speak but
if you're drew brees at this point of
your career you should hopefully take a
step back and maybe check the ego at the
door and say hey we want to win a super
bowl we want to get to a super bowl if
taysom hill
throwing the ball 10 times a game and
running in an extra three or four
is gonna get us there then let's do that
i know drew is intensely competitive but
at some point you have to be critical
with yourself and you have to recognize
you're not throwing the ball like you
used to he's going to be 41 in a month
in a few days so if they do want to get
to the super bowl i mean the job starts
now because whoever ends up with that
one seed if it's the saints or the
seahawks it's basically game over
although look the rams beat the saints
last year in the superdome but but it is
a it's it's a hell of an advantage right
if you're the 49ers you it's not like
the 49ers have a great home field
advantage but i don't think they want to
play in seattle or new orleans for a
birth in the super bowl the key is to
avoid playing in two of the toughest
spots to win on the road and they get a
chance to do it now and you know we
talked about this last year when the
rams played at the saints and maybe this
did help the rams in the nfc
championship game playing a game in that
environment so if you have to do it
again in january you'll be more prepared
for it and they're gonna have to do it
in seattle so if they have to do it in
january they'll be more prepared for it
so win or lose the 49ers may benefit
from the experience on sunday and then
what they have looming in seattle at the
end of the season
yeah brutal schedule for the 49ers you
were like a dog chasing your tail in
that you i think you just said that it's
game over if they have to go to the
saints then you came all the way back
around being like well the 49ers
seahawks and the rams play on sunday
night nbc a great game a rematch of a
game from nine weeks and one day ago
which went right down to the wire
thursday night football an epic game the
missed field goal the back and forth the
bad calls i still remember we were
complaining about pete carroll kicking
the field goal on fourth and one in the
in the first half and they get together
last night game ever at the coliseum
pete carroll's last trip to the coliseum
a lot of subplots there but the bottom
line is this the seahawks have to hold
on to first place in the division the
rams are fighting for their playoff
lives it's going to have a playoff feel
to it
and it's hard to pick against the
seahawks because the brighter the lights
the more likely they just find a way to
pull that horseshoe out of their rear
end and come out of it with a victory
mike ready for me to change your opinion
and as an aside i don't want to say that
i'm having a fantastic show but i'm
having a fantastic show and the bears
are back but for whatever reason sean
mcvay has the seahawks defense number he
has figured out pete carroll's defense
mike ready for this the last four times
these teams have played the rams have
scored 29 points 33 points 36 points and
42 points so i taking the rams here
because i think they can have this
defense with the seahawks i think it's
also one of those situations where the
seahawks are coming off a monday night
victory a fun game short week the rams
need this win they're deep in the
playoff hunt uh so i'm taking the
seahawks here or sorry the rams and the
rams whatever for whatever reason their
offense has been able to take the
seahawks defense behind the woodshed
you like that stat
yeah but here's the thing the the last
time they played jadavian clown he
wasn't playing the way he is now now
he's dealing with that core injury he's
going to need surgery after the season
they're trying to manage him but the
night that he had against the 49ers if
he's even close to that jared goff is
going to be looking out of his ear hole
and the other wild card in all of this
too is todd gurley he had a decent night
when they played in seattle they've been
using him more recently but you know the
thing that they won't talk about is the
knee and he's fighting through a knee
that that is causing him problems but
again they never talk about it it makes
him upset but i think that's part of it
too is he going to get a heavy workload
and is he going to be able to hold up
and if not and if clowney is able to
play like he did a few weeks back i
think that offense is going to have a
harder time than it's ever had against
seattle mike here's one more thing
against seattle and i i think the
seahawks i mean russell wilson is having
mvp season i love watching him play he's
so so so good he's top you know three
quarterback in the nfl the seahawks if
you look at what they've done this year
they haven't blown anyone out the last
time they beat a team by more than one
score was the cardinals in week four the
seahawks have 10 wins the rams have
seven
and the rams are only three points
behind them in point differential the
seahawks are plus 36 on the season the
rams are plus 33 and then guess what the
49ers in between them plus 166. so the
seahawks seem like they have been
winning a bunch of coin flip games that
they could easily be
seven and five instead of ten and two
and so i think that this is one of those
games where if you really dig into it
the rams are going to give their best
effort with their season on the line and
they're gonna win this game on sunday
night
what makes that point differential even
more amazing is the fact that the rams
lost a game by 36 and they still are
close to the seahawks yeah total point
differential i i think as a practical
matter and i'm going to reserve the
right to change my pick on football
night in america for football night
america pick purposes only i've already
picked the seahawks to win but if the
lions upset the vikings and the in the
one o'clock window on sunday that's when
the rams really feel like the
opportunity is there right because
that's when they can catch the vikings
for the sixth seed and i don't think the
lions are gonna do it we've moved on to
that game now though the vikings coming
off of the short week the emotional game
in seattle coming back from the 17-point
deficit or at least trying to the
vikings need to be focused in this when
the last time we saw them at home they
fell behind by 20 points to an inferior
team and for them look on paper they
should win the final four games of the
seasons lions chargers packers bears
they should win all of those three of
them are at home
whether or not they can do it it all
comes back down to kirk cousins can he
deliver with the season on the line and
that stretch of the season being on the
line begins sunday big cat yeah they'll
they will demolish the lions because
this is one of those situations where it
just is such a bad matchup for the lions
remember the first time these guys
played and kirk cousins was able it felt
like every other pass was 50 yards down
the field i think it's gonna be
something similar on sunday when it
comes to
to this game and david blau who played
admirably on thanksgiving day i think
we'll say
um it's always tough though for guys who
are you know rookie guys who have been
kind of thrust in this situation to then
come back the next week even though he's
got a couple extra days of rest and try
to do it again so uh i i have the
vikings i have the vikings big in this
game
yeah i do too but but i i look
they've fallen behind by 20 and 17 each
of the last two games and you can't keep
doing that uh especially when you're
playing a team you should beat
washington at green bay and aaron
rodgers has been openly calling for the
fans at lambeau field to get liquored up
and loud i i think aaron rodgers knows
that this one could go sideways
washington has won two in a row they've
got nothing to lose they're still alive
in the decision for crying out loud and
i think the packers we've seen the
packers that they'll just have those
moments where they slip they get a
little complacent we saw it against the
chargers and i think aaron is concerned
that his
teammates may not be as dialed in
because they assume they're just going
to show up and roll washington and i i
think they will
but i can understand why he's concerned
because uh this is one of those the way
that washington can run the ball with
darius geiss last week well over 100
yards adrian peterson had 99 that that's
that controls the clock shortens the
game gives the offense of green bay
fewer opportunities to make things
happen
this is one again i think the packers
are going to win but i'm not going to be
surprised if washington gives them a
game you know it was 1713 against the
giants last week until rogers made that
great throw on 4th and 10 and the game
started to open up the packers
the packers an amazing story to me
because they're nine and three
and they do not look like a nine and
three team no uh are you gonna give me
the thread the needle on a 13 point line
are you gonna thread the needle here no
i'm not i'm not you know i'm gonna
you're not gonna take the redskins uh
against the spread i i agree with
everything you just said by the way i
think the redskins can keep this game
close with the way they run the football
this is a big test for the packers
defense because if they can't sell out
to stop the run and be like hey dwayne
haskins go ahead and try to beat us they
have bigger problems than we all thought
because this is a game they should be
able to win by a couple touchdowns
you know we did the power rankings
earlier this week and sims asked the
question what is it going to take for
the bills to get out of the nine spot
they get their opportunity to get into
the top five maybe the top four they got
the ravens coming to town on sunday the
bills are nine and three
and it's kind of like a packers style
nine and three where especially for the
bills the schedule hasn't been all that
difficult but
you know at home you're going to have
this is it this is their moment this is
their chance they're one game behind the
patriots isn't that amazing this late in
the season that the patriots haven't run
away with the afc east and they still
have to play the bills again
so i i yeah i think the ravens win this
one because i just think the ravens are
operating on a level higher than every
other franchise right now in the nfl
but it won't surprise me if the bills
make it very interesting and big cat i'm
fascinated by the possibility of lamar
jackson josh allen quarterback rivalry
we're looking for that next tom brady
peyton manning why not these two
yeah i agree um the bills by the way
they need a little more credit than you
just gave them because they have been
good and
of course their schedule no i'm not
pandering because here's my big thing
i know obviously the patriots deserve uh
you know the the history behind them
what they've done the last two decades
has been unprecedented but if you said
mike if i said you right now there's an
afc east team with a great defense maybe
a suspect offense that's beaten up on
really bad opponents in their biggest
games they've lost
would i be talking about the bills or
the patriots because they look very
similar in that respect
yeah i don't disagree with that but i'm
looking back at the season for the bills
i mean they were down 16 nothing to the
jets week one they won by a point giants
28-14 who hasn't beaten them by 14. i'm
looking at the games i mean they have
not had difficult games now they did win
at tennessee which is impressive but
that was before they benched marcus
mariota i don't think they would win at
tennessee now they beat the dolphins by
10. they lost by 18 to the eagles the
eagles who are fighting for their life
right now so they lost to the browns for
crying out loud so i you know i i just i
think that
the hey they're nine and three they
deserve credit they're gonna be the five
seed they're on sunday night football
next week against the the pa the
steelers first time on sunday night
football since 2007. they're fun to
watch what they did last week to the
cowboys was impressive but then again
the bears did the same thing last night
so how impressive is it even though the
bears are back
wow that was a ricochet shot right there
i'm just saying the bills i think
deserve a little bit more credit uh this
is gonna be a fascinating game though
because this is one of those this is a
chance
you want credit this is it here comes
the best team in the nfl into your
building you beat them you'll get the
respect that you want and on the flip
side mike if the ravens come in and
pummel the bills now we're talking
historical like who can stop the ravens
because they've kind of you know last
week was it was a game that they won
that was an ugly game they
absolutely killed the rams now if they
kill the bills you're saying they can
win every single way
chiefs and patriots late sunday
afternoon and look this felt like it was
going to be an afc championship preview
i don't know i don't know what the afc
championship's going to be at this point
it could be ravens texans again for all
i know but yeah the chiefs need this one
uh they still have an outside shot at a
bye the patriots desperately need they
don't want to lose two in a row they
don't want to be falling apart in
december this is what they're supposed
to be figuring it out big cat
mike this one is a model pick it's a
system pick
the world is down on the patriots
it's december they're playing in
foxborough onto cincinnati game it's an
honda cincinnati game the chiefs were
the original basis for the on to
cincinnati five years ago now they're
going to get on to cincinnati and next
week the patriots play cincinnati so if
they lose bill belichick can bring that
back out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports